Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
uh,
December 10th,
2012 as it going,
uh,
for those of you who follow me on Twitter,
you guys know that I have a special guest this week.
Um,
and we're going to get right to it cause he's already bugging me with this
fucking giant shirt.
We have the one and only Michael Rappaport from every film that you've ever
Fuckin Huh?
Nice to a nice to have you on here.
You're reinventing the podcast cause you just said podcasts,
your accent.
The p a wd cast.
Yeah.
And I'm talking shit about accents.
That's the,
uh,
that's the Boston podcast.
I know,
but I like that.
That's the Boston accent.
I know.
I got it.
No,
It goes,
a lot of people when they do that,
you actually pick up on that,
that it's that we say pa,
WWE,
we say Boston,
ba w like Boston.
And people always go,
where are you from?
And I say,
you know,
I grew up outside of Boston and they go,
oh,
fasting.
It's like,
no dude.
Boston like saw would be no,
I gotcha.
Yeah,
I know I'm not wanting to talk about accents,
but I I like,
I like the Boston accent.
I like it cause it's more fucked up than the New York accent.
That's why I like this.
All the pens,
it all depends.
I can tell you that I have to adjust these levels.
So not oranges,
but I do like the,
I like the Boston accent and then I liked the Chicago accident.
Their shit is way out there.
Yeah.
And that's one of the,
I can't even duplicate,
like I can't eat,
I haven't been out to the Midwest enough like in Chicago to even try and like do
a bad,
it sounds like everybody's doing an SNL character.
The Chicago accident is,
it's just,
I love it.
He likes to Chicago.
I just like working class accents.
Like Boston New York was when I think about you as you've lived out here forever
and you never lost your accent.
Yeah.
I have my state had the,
the voice coaches and all that saying like,
yeah,
Michael,
if you want to work more in this industry,
they warned me.
But you know,
all the actors that I really admire,
they never truly lose their accent.
So I was like,
if they don't have to do it,
and I'm of course it's good as them.
And I'm of course referring to like the Deniros,
the Patinas.
Cause you know when you mentioned de Niro,
Pacino Rapaport,
it's like Deniro Rapaport Brando wrap up,
but sometimes they put Britain,
Europe Opportunity Brando Rapaport and that's fine.
That's fine.
You don't get upset,
don't get upset.
But you know,
I lost it a little bit here and there and you know,
you told me you could tone it down,
you can do variations on it when you go back.
I like,
cause when I go back to Boston,
like,
uh,
and I run into some people who really have it hardcore,
I like burst out laughing going like,
especially when it's a beautiful girl,
Massachusetts in that heinous accent like he is.
Sure.
Yeah.
They'll say stuff like that.
And it's coming out of their mouth and they sound like they're fucking,
like there's something,
they have brain damage and there is those times where I'm just like,
wow,
I eat them.
I used to and I never thought I had it that bad.
I have some old standup tapes that I will never show anybody.
Oh,
where you could really hear it.
I'll do it.
I'm a brutal,
brutal,
like I would win an Oscar like if Boston accent,
how bad it was.
And I still have it pretty bad.
This is good.
But when we were working in Boston years,
cause we were playing boss,
of course I was,
my,
my Boston accent was,
it's pretty pretty well I was just down east coast so I,
yeah,
well I was the,
I was the,
I was the black sheep of the family,
so I was like,
oh he must've left Boston.
So yeah,
he went upstate.
But yours was yours.
It was hard.
I was like,
oh cause it was you and you.
There was other bosses to people.
I was like,
people that are there really got that shit down.
You know,
people were really in their native,
their native tongue.
Yeah.
No,
no,
I didn't get anything down.
I just,
I was from there.
Right.
I don't do any,
uh,
I don't do any work,
but just to let people know,
we did a movie this,
uh,
this summer called the heat with Sandra Bullock and Melissa McCarthy and the
director of a bridesmaid.
Paul Feig.
Yup.
Comedy r rated comedy definitely was really funny.
Every nurse is a lie.
Everybody curses a lot.
And this we're,
we're,
we're a dysfunctional family.
Yeah.
We all play,
we all,
and we all play brothers,
which is of course when I,
when I tweeted out that you were going to be on the podcast here and I was just
saying,
if you have any questions,
let me know.
And I knew it was going to be a bunch of,
what are you guys brothers,
the pigment thing and all that.
The red head,
Sun,
the sun,
cancer,
twins,
all that shit.
They didn't,
they weren't even that good.
And that's the thing.
They send them to me like they're gonna make me laugh.
And they think they're so fucking clever.
And it was basically 70 of the exact same joke,
but there was a couple,
uh,
I should actually read the funny one.
What were some of the,
what were some of the highlights you want to hear some of these?
Sometimes I set myself up on Twitter to see like,
wait,
if I'm going to get some good stuff and people make me laugh,
even if they're insulting me,
I'll see if I can,
I fuck you if you insult me on Twitter,
by the way,
you know,
I don't,
I don't respond back.
I might just retweet because you know my kids,
I got kids and it's,
it's not,
it's what good does it do to.
I used to,
when I first got on Twitter,
I would get into arguments with people,
oh,
you're making that day.
I know that guy from true romance,
I'm actually interacting with him.
He told me to fuck off and they re they retweet.
Fuck your mother.
And they,
they,
they put that on there.
All right,
well this is a good one.
Why did stupid Fox cancel?
He's show the war at home.
So that's a nice one.
They were a fan.
Politics man.
Politics,
politics in show business.
Just like politics and politics.
Let's see what we got here.
Let me think.
God,
do you think you were separated at birth?
That's funny.
Ha ha ha.
That's all you unblock.
You and him were the same guy.
There's like another one.
Ah,
ask Rappaport if he realizes he's white.
Yeah,
I love that.
Just because you're from Brooklyn and you have an appreciation for,
uh,
a culture other than your own.
Um,
where are we at?
I was just going to be more of this.
I'm not going to waste time fucking blowing through this stuff,
but,
uh,
what was I going to ask you?
I was going to get into this thing.
Well,
we'll hope the whole way,
this whole podcast,
you being on the podcast came about,
wasn't just that we,
you know,
we're working together was that we both have dogs.
Right?
And I started talking about,
you know,
the big thing is curved your dog.
If you have a dog like a New York City,
I think that they were the first ones came up with the preschool pooper scooper,
a pooper scooper where I was from.
And uh,
yeah,
that basically to get the dog shit off.
Right.
And then that became a thing cause when I was a kid,
if you'd dog took a shit,
it just took a shit.
Right?
It was just outside and barely have a license.
So now you supposed to pick up after it.
So I never owned a dog in New York,
but I own one out here and I always pick up after her.
And you had this interesting duality is far as when and where you pick up after
your dog.
Yes.
Well here's the deal.
Okay.
I grew up,
I never had dogs.
So when I actually got my first dog,
I lived in Los Angeles and of course,
you know,
you want to follow it and got the dog,
the license and you know,
pick up after the dog.
And I was good and I would carry the shitbags and,
and I would pick up the shit.
And then I had two dogs so it would be,
you know,
you'd have to bring like three or four shit bags per trip cause each dog who
knows what's going to happen.
But the thing is then I,
then I moved to Los and then I moved back to New York with my two dogs.
And in New York,
this is where the World Cup,
what kind of dogs but months,
two months,
two months.
Uh,
and,
and but this is where the conversation between me and bill about dog shit and
shit bags got interesting cause I said I don't use shitbags anymore.
Now back living in Los Angeles and bill there was a just a sense of judgment.
You don't,
you shitbag in La,
in La,
in La.
I don't use shit bags.
And the reason why,
here's the deal in New York,
I use shitbags I clean up all the die in New York cause you're like no,
no,
no.
That's not why prejudice.
No.
I would pick up the shit and then be able to walk to the corner and drop the
shit bag in the garbage pail.
K in Los Angeles there's not.
And so the New York,
there's garbage cans on every corner there is,
yes,
there is even caddy corner,
there's garbage cans.
Sometimes they're filled all the way to the top and the garbage is spilling out,
but at least it's the place to get rid of the shit bag full of shit.
In Los Angeles,
for those who are not familiar with less interest,
there are not garbage cans on every corner.
So therefore when you are walking your dog and two dogs,
when I made up my own rule about this,
you,
you pick up the dog crap,
I don't want to keep saying shit.
You pick up the door,
crap in the shit bag.
All right,
and then you carry it and you could be walking three,
four,
five,
six blocks with it.
Now I'm caring.
I have two dogs on a leash,
medium sized dogs,
50 60 pound dogs were to shitbags right by my side.
It's not like you could shake the shit bag and put it in your pocket and then
dump it out like it's like,
like a like a candy wrapper.
Right?
That's not cool.
To be half to walk around with two shoots and it's not the picking up.
It's the caring of the shit that you're carrying of it.
Now I could change my rule and pick up the shit,
put it in shit bags and they'd throw that right on the side of the street and
then someone else has to deal with it.
But a person,
but just to play devil's advocate,
play it.
You can you plant,
you got the tooth dogs.
All right.
You live in a nice upstanding neighborhood.
You're considered a good citizen of this,
of the snap by anyone who knows me.
I appreciate that to your neighbors,
like see like your dog's takes shits and you just walk up like,
let me ask you this.
So when you're in La,
if your dog's taking a shit,
the least put your head on a swivel and be like,
oh,
there's a basket over there.
I will pick this lump shit.
I do not buy shit bags anymore.
My zero tolerance.
I have a,
I don't fuck with shit bags anymore.
And the reason why I don't fuck with shit bags in words because I'm not walking
around with bags of shit for blocking block and block and block.
It's just not cool.
It's not cool.
It's degrading.
And here's who is it degrading to to walk with Oh,
steaming hot bag of shit for like you know it from underneath them.
I got two to one.
I have one dog,
Stanley died our Ip Stanley,
sorry to hear that.
It's Kay.
She was old but,
but,
but you know,
even now I have a big dog.
Dog takes big shits,
you know,
and in the bag and then I can't walk text cause you've got a text when you're
walking your dog.
That's when you get with Texas.
Yeah.
That's good techs time when you're walking your dog,
I can't walk the dog who I sometimes take off the leash,
she's trained and then carry a shitbag.
Hey I'm just not doing it.
And now I'll tell you something.
I'll tell you something.
So you say upstanding citizen and I'm like this the game,
I'll refer to it as the game,
the shit game.
Listen if some,
if a dog shits on my yard,
I don't it's part of the game or you don't get mad if so.
Nope,
you shit on my yard.
It is what it is.
My dog shits in your yard.
It is what it is now sometimes there is a tinge of guilt if I know that it's,
it's cause I know some of my neighbors so I'll be like,
oh shit.
You know it could like there's a six year old there.
He's probably going to wind up playing footprint,
stepping in it,
running in it.
Oh there's a six year old girl and he's like,
when your dog takes a shit,
do you stand there?
Defiantly like I know my dog taking a shit.
I'm not picking up or do you pretend to be talking on the phone and not notice
it or you a warm about it?
I'm a warm about it.
I'm not going to front listen this.
Sometimes I'll faint like I'm bending over and I'm doing something that pick it
up or if somebody goes pay your dog just went to the,
Oh you know he's sick.
I ran out of shit bags.
You know like he's right.
I am not going to get cause you buck because?
Because I've had confrontations.
One Dude,
two people literally say hey Michael Rappaport that happened.
One dog took a shit one because now,
now that you have great,
you've had fame for a while but you're not some random,
they can't that you get blue with this fucking asshole did you?
They still can't believe I will have to accept that.
I will not argue that it's part of the shit game.
So I got to turn this down man cause we're fucking getting into this.
I think I got the level's too high.
If you want to insult me,
criticize me,
judge me on,
on my policies with shitbags fine.
It's not a Los Angeles thing.
I love Los Angeles.
I'm from New York.
It's just you put a garbage can on every corner.
This will go out the door.
You got a with me,
put it on rock.
You have demands.
Listen,
I'm not walking,
I'm not walking more than a half a block with a shitbag it.
He's the most famous person you've seen walking with a shitbag for a good six
blocks.
You ever just been driving around and you'd be like,
oh there's Mary Tyler Moore with the sharing and shit.
I had never seen if you've ever seen somebody with a shitbag somebody famous.
No,
but I think that they have like the assistant walks their dog.
Maybe that's what your problem is to once you get famous dude,
you need,
you need like an assistant.
I need to walk the dog.
I need that tech's time.
And to clear my head.
It got got two kids,
get out of the house for a few minutes.
I and I do my thing,
but I will tell you one time,
do your kids know that you don't pick up your shit?
Unfortunately,
yes.
And I,
and I say,
you know,
don't,
this is a three pronged problem.
Yeah.
Cause it's just too Ken and it's creating other little kids.
But I,
I explained to them the reason why,
because if you in most inches,
if you carry that shit bag,
you either have to make it back to your house,
say your 10 blocks away from your house.
Dude,
I live it every morning you walk with a shit bag,
10 blocks,
you know,
I almost,
it's almost,
remember that Tom Hanks movie where he was like talking to the soccer ball,
like literally like it's to that point and isn't,
it disrupts once you pick up the shit and you have the shit bag,
that's the only thing you're thinking about.
And then sometimes you get so relaxed it,
it's just like you forget that it's even in your hand and it's like just
dangling.
It's not cool,
but gets to the point now you know what it is when she takes a fucking horrific
shit.
This isn't gonna be the Shit podcasts here,
by the way,
when she takes one of those horrific shits steamer that you can literally see
through the bag and then you'll walk in with it and then some hot chick comes
jogging by you just,
you just feel like an asshole.
It's degrading,
man.
It's the grading and that's my thing.
I had left a grading.
I've had,
it's,
it is.
I've had people say,
pick your shit up,
you know law.
I had one guy,
my dog,
and I told this guy,
shook his hand afterwards,
my dog shat his yard.
I kept walking.
I told him I the dog is sick.
This guy's a prick.
Anyway,
I is.
When he first moved in the neighborhood and I didn't know he was much,
why is he a prick?
Because he called you out or cause he know,
I respected that.
We,
we got into some other thing later.
He called [inaudible] my kid and some other kids call them really bad names and
it was bad and it was it because they weren't picking up.
No,
it wasn't even that.
He was just one of those guy like it was whatever.
But my dog shat in his yard.
He's some had a weird accent too.
And,
and,
and then he said something,
I said,
the dog is sick or whatever.
The,
what am I,
two or three I excuses.
I had to kept going,
this fucking guy.
I was walking three,
four blocks away,
picked up the shit in a Shitbag,
drove up to me.
So he picked up the shit and shit bag and brought the shit back and his car.
I respected it and he came up to me and your dog shit and he handed me the shit
bag and I said,
you know what I respect that took the shit.
I said,
it's shake.
He didn't want to shake manager please,
please.
I shook his hand and he went on,
you know when I dropped the ship.
But you're acting like your noble that this guy had to go pick up your shit and
be like,
you know,
and I respect that.
I respect that.
You just picked up my dog rat.
If fucking
it's good.
Depends on what you feed them.
You feed them the human food.
Then this shits is healthy as our shit's fine.
It's good for the grass.
But let's have you noticed that by the way.
What?
Anything can take his shit on your yard and it'll make the grass greener except
for a human being and I've Shat on my own yard.
Okay.
We got to get into this.
That's my shift bed.
Sorry,
I apologize for the cough.
No,
no bro.
Listen man,
I fucking,
I bought these fucking Hook in cigars and I put them in the fucking humor door
and I had it turned up to fucking high and it fucked up the cigars like this.
They get this fucking acceptable.
There's like fucking little bug eggs in there.
If it's up too high.
They like hatch.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what I haven't,
I think,
I think I got a virus in me.
It's gradually,
this is the most disgusting.
First 10 discuss people.
I'm not,
I'm not like one of these people with,
you know,
who likes to talk about shit.
Right.
It's on a scale.
A scale of one to 10.
Yeah.
As far as your,
your upstanding citizen count,
10 being the best one being like,
I can't wait for that motherfucker to move out of where,
where are you aside from dog stuff.
I'm a good neighbor.
I consider myself a good neighbor.
I do,
let's like Manson say,
aside from fucking getting people killed,
I'm a good drawer.
Aside from my dog.
My dog is harmless.
The dog couldn't hurt a fly.
Listen,
my house got broken into.
The fucking dog was sleeping.
It's set on the police report.
It said the dog was sleeping.
It freaked me out about that.
You are home and somebody came in and just like the boldness of that just came
into your house at night.
Took like whatever laptop or some bullshit stuff and my dog didn't wake up.
Cops come dog fucking bolts out there.
Cops pull a pepper spray.
No,
no,
don't,
don't pepper spray him.
Right.
When he had his moment to shine,
to bark attack something,
he was sleeping.
You know,
I made this reference the other day.
it's like,
he's like a,
that dude Bobby in Saturday night fever driving around the crowd.
What were you guys I was [inaudible] I was looking for exactly.
I would,
I would have done something.
You actually made me.
I got a fucking got guts in Santa Fe fever.
Remember they beat up guts.
That's why they went back and got them all.
That's fine.
It's only seen it a couple of times.
Send a fever.
I know,
I know.
That's a big one for you,
for you guys.
You guys in Brooklyn,
you're from Brooklyn,
but I'm from Manhattan.
From Manhattan can make that mistake.
I went to school in Brooklyn.
I have a lot of friends in Brooklyn.
I have a lot of affiliations in Brooklyn,
but I'm from enhance.
You know people.
You go to Brooklyn,
they know you.
I got Ya.
I got to Brooklyn Path.
Well let me ask you this as a out before we get into this shit.
We know what the Shit topic here.
I'm fine with.
You brought it up.
You brought,
I'm comfortable with it.
You were fascinated by,
I am comfortable with my stance on it,
you know,
cause you know what it is.
I have such a fucking need to be liked.
I got,
when we come back after this talking about your needs to be liked.
I'm going to talk about that and how I just found out for my fucking
neighborhood loud.
I am.
Oh,
okay.
I had no,
I had that problem too.
Okay.
I think it's an east coast,
but just loud.
All right,
here we go.
Um,
the man,
great system,
everybody,
uh,
this holiday season,
think the man great.
What is the man great you ask or maybe you didn't ask but the copy did.
Um,
there are 100% made in America cast iron grilling greats that are
revolutionizing the way people grill named one of 2012 best grilling accessories
by men's health magazine.
Man grates are perfect.
The perfect gift this holiday season,
it's the worst read ever.
It's really good.
Click on the man.
Great banner on a billboard.com for the 1999 holiday special.
Do you get one for free?
Yeah,
they hooked me up.
They've given me two so far.
So if you want one I can give it to you.
Why not?
I use it.
They're awesome.
It's basically,
you know like when you have like a little Hibachi.
Yeah.
And they give you those little debt.
Little bitchy great on top.
It's like for a grilled cheese sandwich.
I'm ready.
This thing you put it in,
you put this system on,
it's the big thick ones,
like a in a steak house.
So you can really like mark up your states.
You get more heat on it.
It actually makes the food tastes a hundred percent ferals good every Monday
morning podcast or to comes with a heavy duty grilling brush.
Again,
that's the man great grill enhancement system.
Order today@billbird.com the guy who invented,
it's going to be fucking standing next to George Foreman and the,
I got $100 million line,
exactly short form and got a lot of money off those pills and that's one of
those things I wish that I came up with.
Let me,
let me do the stamps.com and we're done with the advertising a stamps.com
everybody would love to have the post office in your house rather than having to
go there.
Why wouldn't you when the holidays are almost here,
you don't have time to go to the post office traffic parking.
It will be packed and everyone mailing holiday gifts and packages.
Thank you.
So what do you do?
You go to stamps.com instead with stamps.com you can avoid all the hassle of
going to the post office during the busy holiday season.
Everything you would do at the post office,
you can do right from your desk.
You can buy and print official US postage using your own computer and printer,
print postage for any letter or package the incident.
You need it.
Then the mailman man picks it up.
It's so easy.
I use stamps.com to send out all my DVDs every weekend while the weekends and
I'm working,
I should say,
uh,
you should use it to right now.
Get this special offer when you use my last name bur bur get a no risk trial
plus $110 bonus.
That includes a digital scale and up to $55 in free postage.
Even if you don't use it,
you get $55 in stamps a don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
[inaudible].
All right.
Back to the podcast.
Do it.
Um,
so today,
right?
We saw Bruce Springsteen by the way,
the other night down in Anaheim.
Oh,
I thought you saw him around here.
No,
no,
no.
Sorry.
That's cool.
Yeah.
And I had never seen him and I was one of those guys going through it.
I don't get it.
All he does is sing about jersey,
but like so many people I know who were borderline.
Did you do a southern accent?
He's from Jersey,
but he does a southern accent sometimes,
which is weird to me.
I,
he didn't do that tonight.
I'm talking about,
I'm just,
you know,
he's,
he does like a southern accent,
but he's from Jersey.
He's the,
he's the common man.
But you're from Jersey.
Yeah.
I like guy.
Go ahead.
I don't want to show him the Bruce.
He went and I was down there like,
hi man.
You know,
all right.
I was gonna say,
born to be wild,
born to run or whatever.
I'll listen to this shit,
dude.
I got to tell you something,
man.
The fact that I ever think that I gave a performance after seeing what that guy
did,
do four songs in the,
I'm already blown away.
He's blown away.
Bands that are in their twenties and thirties that I've seen just fucking
killing his voice.
Sounds unreal.
Goes out to the middle of the crowd.
He's standing on this stage out there.
People go and fucking nuts,
and then he just lays back into the crowd and crowd surfs like 70 rows.
That's cool.
Up to the,
as a band keeps playing,
that's crazy,
right?
As he gets onto the stage,
boom,
they go right into the closing verse.
Dude,
that's,
that's encore.
That's,
you know,
that's somebody closing out a great concert.
That this fourth song.
That's crazy.
And it didn't peak there.
It just kept,
he wore me out,
dude.
I was sitting.
How long did he go for?
Three and a half hours of that.
He is no joke,
dude.
It was,
it was,
it was sick.
And the thing about that,
that I love so much that he doesn't have to do three and a half hours.
He loves to perform.
Totally,
totally get your money's worth like that.
[inaudible] he was like,
what do you like it or not like Bruce,
that guy.
I got this like longer than Schindler's list.
We put the fuck Bruce.
I got to go,
man,
I got to take my dog.
I have to take a shit.
You know what?
Every time like I was,
I'm so old,
like my back's killing me and shit and they do that shit where they have like a,
they hit the final note of the song and Weinberg's doing the simple wash and
then playing a chord and you think he's going to be like,
thanks a lot.
Anaheim.
You are great.
And he always just goes one,
two,
three,
four and they go into them.
I'm like,
oh my God,
that's crazy.
Like he just kept thinking that this guy couldn't get a dude and it's fucking
Anaheim.
What are the cheesiest like?
Just like he said it not me as bill talking by Anaheim Dude.
It doesn't even look real.
I think back in the day when they had like all the orange groves has bent some
sort of personality.
It's just one fucking strip mall after another.
It looks like a giant,
like it's Disneyland down there.
Right?
Like there's no,
there isn't that feeling them any sort of culture.
Right.
Either way.
And he's down there active performing like he's in giant state.
That's cool.
Yeah.
I,
I respect them and that's,
yeah.
So anyway,
so today that fucking born to run song,
which I never,
never was into.
So I'm up in the bathroom and I'm singing it,
but I'm doing different lyrics and I'm singing to Nia and it's all vulgar and I
did all your born come.
No,
no,
no.
I was just saying how it was starting off saying,
uh,
I was just singing about what a great guy I was and that Nia doesn't appreciate
it and all this shit that I put in the cadence of born to run.
Yeah.
And then there's somehow there was something about banging you in the ass.
Just,
it was really,
it was that cold.
He's really vulgar.
That's cool.
Then it go some like banging.
Yes.
Like maybe hey like you know,
I don't need a Christmas gift or bang you in the end I will let me do it.
Maybe we can do,
but she'll never let me do that.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I was singing that and got it.
You got to ask.
I got all the way to the dat,
Dat,
dat,
it loudest,
fucking hell.
So I walked out of the bathroom,
I didn't realize my bedroom window was,
and I know Amy,
I go,
do you like that Bruce Springsteen impression?
And before she could answer,
I heard somebody just in a talking voice goes now and I was like,
Oh shit.
It was your neighbor.
Yeah.
And I started thinking like,
Holy Fuck,
how much did they been hearing?
How loud I am,
I,
and then Nia,
I kept wanting need to make me feel better,
but she just goes,
you know,
you're,
you're loud.
You're,
there's times I pull up in the car and I hear you on the phone and it's making
me like really like self conscious.
Like fuck him.
I'm,
I'm that loud.
And I felt bad until you fucking come.
And I'm like,
you come and I,
and I,
you hit the buzzer and I pick it up.
I'm like,
hello.
And you start screaming,
Derek cheat or like loud as fuck.
And I'm like,
it may be,
it's just an east coast.
Well,
it still,
as far as upstanding citizens and loudness,
I,
I've come to terms with the fact that my neighbors know everything about me.
If they wanted it to like,
you know,
start a scandal on me or they know my whole life because yeah,
I got this buddy of mine,
Becky's big giant Yankee fence.
We have these epic Paul versus epic fucking,
uh,
arguments about sports where I'm just like,
I got him on speakerphone and I'm yelling like,
we're in a crowded bar.
I can't imagine.
I feel bad for my neighbors and what they've heard.
I know they've heard me doing,
my neighbors on this side have kids and the stuff that all the time,
it's just like,
she doesn't give me dirty looks.
So,
but I look at it like she has a toddler and I can never hear her kid.
Well,
if you'd never hear the little snotty nose loudmouth kids screaming and crying,
she probably never hears it.
You should ask her,
see,
that's what I need to hear me,
hear me sick cunt or fuck you.
Or cause I don't want to offend your kids and then you should just ask her.
I Dunno.
I think that would get a,
they get weird,
but whatever.
I should be mean to say,
Yo,
I still,
it takes a lot for me to be embarrassed at this point.
All,
you know,
just in general,
you become immune to humiliation when you get into this big,
like every audition you go into and you eat your balls after awhile you just
don't feel it anymore.
But that I literally got,
uh,
that made me feel,
I felt I was embarrassed.
I was like,
wow.
She,
she heard all of that.
And like just the,
uh,
the way she said no to was,
this was not the first time I heard my loud voice.
She's,
yeah,
she's,
this is just an option.
You just open the window up for her.
The,
the opened the window literally for her to get involved with the conversation.
I was fantasizing about all these cool comebacks that I wish I said,
but in the end I just had to realize like,
you know what she was yeah,
she was right.
She was right.
I um,
I've come to terms with it.
I got loud speaking voice and it,
but I'm in my house.
I'm not bringing it down so you hear what you hear and that's it.
But I turn music up,
I got a pool and I turned the fountains on when I'm there.
It's not like,
it's not our fault that fucking house is a two feet.
Like I could literally take a running leap up my,
if I could leak through my bedroom window and I couldn't be landing on the roof
of the house next door.
Right.
I know we're on top of each other,
not the house.
I mean it slammed into the side,
but you know what I mean,
be there.
I would be there.
I would definitely be there.
So this is some sports questions I'm trying to,
and I know people want to know about your movies and shit,
but I just figured,
Hey,
yes,
you've answered
all of that is us or whatever.
Silly at times.
All right,
well before I go into more sports shit.
Okay.
We haven't started but I always end up talking sports.
Yeah.
Like you know,
right out of the gate dude,
you were in one of the greatest movies of,
uh,
of my life,
a true romance and a,
I was wondering like,
you were basically roommates with Brad [inaudible],
Brad Pitt,
Brad Pitt at that point.
It was just about to be almost Brad Pitt at that point.
Like he was,
he had done like Thelma and Louise.
He had done,
um,
the movie with Robert Redford.
He had done stuff,
he'd done California and,
and you know,
he was,
he wasn't the superstar,
but you knew that he was going to be,
that he was very well liked and,
and you know,
there was,
he was,
he was about to be Brad Pitt.
So you,
it was excited that you were just sitting at a yes.
Good looking son of a bitch with his ABS.
None.
No,
no,
he was,
he was real.
He was totally cool.
And,
and,
um,
you know,
the thing about true romance was that,
first of all,
the script was so great when you read the script,
it just read you like,
you know,
Quentin Tarantino scripts.
They just read so easy and you're just like laughing and like,
what the fuck?
And it was so a reverend.
And so,
you know,
every,
I'd say about 95% of what wound up insurance was,
was written like,
it's so active,
friendly,
like it's hard to score it up.
And so,
you know,
I had heard like,
initially it was like,
okay,
Christian Slater and Patricia Arquette and Patricia Arquette,
I had just seen in Sean Penn's movie called Indian runner.
That was like one of the first things she did.
And she was great in that.
And I was like,
oh,
this is going to be dope.
And you know,
Christian Slater was like,
you know,
right at that time he was,
it was perfect.
And then you heard,
oh,
well Gary Oldman's plane,
um,
whatever the pimp and the pimp,
I can't remember the character's name and oh,
that's cool.
And then val Kilmer's playing Elvis.
Really Salt.
So you,
you were already,
I wasn't cache.
I was,
I had been going in for another part I hadn't been going in for,
for,
for um,
one of the mobsters and um,
and,
and actually actually at the,
actually I got cast as one of the mobsters as one of the younger mobsters.
So I would,
I always like kind of like,
oh,
you know,
you would have been in that scene with,
if I succeed I would've been in there like,
yeah,
around there.
And then,
so then you heard like,
yeah,
walking's planned the mobs a holy shit.
And then Dennis Hopper's plane is that Holy Shit.
And,
and Sammy and I'm 24 years old at this point.
I had done zebra head,
a little part in poetic justice just to meet Tupac.
I was like,
it was like I just want it to meet him like I and then and then,
and then a little part in,
in,
in a a move,
another movie and then,
and then,
sure.
Oh Man.
So I mean I was such a fan of all these guys and I was so sort of excel and
everybody was and but how big was Tupac by the time?
Uh,
he was,
he was super oc for what he was doing.
Poetic Justice.
He was,
as soon as he was,
he was at,
he was like a star and he,
I thought he kinda came out and he was with the who?
Who's that guy?
The humpty dance guys and like 90,
89 90 and then he broke out on his own like 91 92 I would think.
He was still like on the ride he was on,
he wasn't what he became like he became this iconic,
I love to know,
this was after juice.
I loved his music.
He wasn't the star that he became like after,
you know,
when he was with death row and he really took it to the next level.
But he was,
he was big.
I mean he was,
you know,
and I,
I thought he was,
I thought juice has performance in this movie.
Juice was just like,
it was incredible.
And I was just,
I at that time I met was still huge fan of movies and huge fan of actors,
but like at that time,
like I would become a namerd with people's performances and I d I liked his
music and I had a funny kind of relationship following him because I was friends
with Jada Pinkett and she kept telling me before he did anything,
my friend Tupac,
he's going to be a big star two and I had heard his name and then he came out
with Humpty dance and he came out with that,
you know,
that one verse on digital on the ground.
And then,
you know,
then of course his solo album and then juice.
And I was just like,
damn,
this,
this guy is special.
And so to do that,
it was John Singleton who was just off of Boyz in the hood and I'm Janet Jackson
would Janet Jackson was like Jenny's Jackson,
you worked with everybody.
It was your first week,
your first,
by the time you're 24,
you were with,
there's a lot every icon out there.
Yeah.
And then it meant a lot to me.
Like,
I mean I,
I get excited now,
but like at the time I was,
so I was young and I was like,
I was like really excited.
So true romance.
And it was Quentin Tarantino who had done reservoir dogs.
Um,
natural born killers had come out.
I think he didn't direct us,
he didn't direct it.
He wrote it.
And I had met Quentin originally at the Sundance Film Festival because the year
that reservoir dogs was,
there was the same year that Zebra had was there.
And that was a big deal for me.
It was a big deal for him.
He was nobody,
I was nobody.
I was really nobody.
And you know,
that was a really exciting time for independent filmmaking.
So,
you know,
the script was being passed around in Hollywood fall,
like a smaller community.
At that time everybody was talking about a true romance and I got cast as one of
these mobsters and then this one was in it and that one was in it.
And then I'll see they cast you as the is one of the mobsters.
So what happened?
So then they,
in the script,
Dick Richie,
the character I wanted to play was written as a black,
it was written as Dick Richie,
black,
young actor,
blah blah,
blah blah.
So they were looking at young,
uh,
young act of black actors,
right.
He was just written that way.
Um,
and then they,
they,
they weren't finding them.
And um,
Tony Scott,
the Great Tony Scott,
rest and peace,
great guy.
So much fun to work with.
Um,
the,
they called me in the Mary for new,
uh,
who was a casting system,
who is now a huge casting director and um,
oh man,
I got to fix this because the other casting director,
I can't remember her name,
I never remember names they gave me.
They gave me a big break.
Anyway,
but I remember I got the word that from my agent that Mary renew was like,
she thinks you're a Dick Richie and you should play that.
And it was very true.
I never considered the park cause I wasn't even brought in.
She was like the way you are.
And I was like that.
Like I was like looking for my big break and you know,
and I was just really sort of wide eyed and I don't know how actors,
that's the hardest thing ever.
I don't know how you guys do
it.
What?
It's so much easier.
It was a stand up that doing an hour long commercial is,
that's your special people.
You just do it enough eventually.
That's how I finally got little,
little parts that I'm been getting lately was just going through that.
The shit that you guys do.
Like I've done a couple of pilots and like the second the pilot is over,
you know,
I'm going to go go tell jokes and these other guys are like,
well,
unemployed again.
And she's like,
I don't know.
I don't know how you'd do that.
I didn't want to,
no,
no.
It's cool.
I want to talk to about,
because you said something when we were working together about the standup
thing,
which is like your independent,
if you're good at it,
which you are and you're successful at it,
it's you have it never unemployed.
Like I knew the full thing.
I don't have that level of strength to do,
uh,
to try and make it just as an why man.
I had a passion for Standup,
but just,
just,
just sit there and be like,
all right,
I'm going to fucking wake table.
Fuck that and I'm going to get a bit part and be in this movie,
this giant production and then you know,
every fucking movie you see there's like a hundred whatever.
What 40 actors work on them.
Yeah.
It's like two people that continue on.
Exactly.
And then the,
then maybe somebody in,
in the other whatever,
38 get something and then everybody else goes back to fucking waiting tables.
You would just,
you were in a movie,
which is the biggest thing ever to everybody in your hometown and stuff.
And they,
I don't know that they,
and it's like how fucking hard that it's tough.
It's tough.
It's so true.
Just uh,
it,
the,
the uh,
on the scene,
I'm not saying like,
you know,
as opposed to digging a ditch,
it's not physically hard,
but the emotionally it's hard emotionally to go from that.
It's emotionally,
it is hard.
Yeah.
To then fucking going back to,
to waiting the tables and uh,
I dunno and just know when you're good enough.
Right.
Miss just have and then you and knowing you couldn't have paid is being proved
cause you,
you got a part.
Yeah.
But it might not pay the bills much longer than you know,
you know,
when you're,
when you could be like,
what are you,
if you were a quarterback and you came out,
you first start you through 300 yards and for some inexplicable reason you sit
on the bench again for two fucking years.
Tom Brady crazy.
Like that's like Brady's thing.
Like he was just sitting there and sitting there.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
It's being an of the emotional highs and lows are,
are,
are tough.
But I could never do it.
It's,
it's,
it sucks.
It's the worst part of it.
That's so much of it does.
It seems like it sucks.
That's why it always makes me laugh when,
when,
when actors,
there'll be like,
standup has this weird sort of like it's respected and they also look at you
like you're slapping yourself in the head with a rubber chicken where it's like
it's,
it is obnoxious.
Just ask my neighbor,
he's fucking obnoxious.
But then like there is this respect for it,
but like all the balls it takes to get on that.
Like I feel like there is a lot of humiliation but the level,
I just couldn't handle the fucking stress.
Like I would be doing a movie,
God willing and I would just be thinking the whole time as I'm doing this.
Like I have to be so fucking unreal in this thing or else I go back to
Applebee's.
Fuck.
Like I don't know how they do it.
It's tough.
You got.
That's why when people ask me if anybody,
they,
you know,
people
always ask,
what do you,
what do you need to be to,
what do you need to do to be in this business?
And I always say,
you have to,
it has to be something you have to do.
If it can't be something that you kind of want to do,
I might do this business.
You will,
if you're,
if it's not something that you have to do,
if it's intrinsically in you that you have to do it,
stop.
Don't even try to do it because there's too much.
It takes too much out of you.
You have to do,
it has to be something that's within you.
It's like if you are a writer,
like what do I have to do to be a writer?
Right?
Keep going.
Keep it ended that.
And if you're in it just because you're not on riding on,
you know the Sopranos.
Gee,
if you,
you have to,
it has to be like something that's organic.
Just like,
like I really just have to have that,
that psycho,
once you start down the road,
there's no way I'm stopping no matter how many times like I did,
I got to tell you what's of course crazy as,
as I know a couple of comics throughout the years that these legendary guys who
never got beyond doing open mikes are doing the occasional spot and they fucking
bomb 98% I bomb like quit the business bomb and they've stuck with it for 2025
fucking years.
And you see like all these funny people that you run into on the road and
they'll say,
she like,
dude,
like as much as I'm shitting on some of the stuff,
people around in Twitter,
there's people out there that write really funny shit,
right?
And I think God damn,
that's funny.
And then have to fucking great.
Right.
But you know,
try going on stage on and I'll do it.
I can never do it.
Like I never do it because it's the whole fear of bombing and then you see this
guy just night after night after night,
basically living the horror that everybody does it and he and he just keeps
fucking right back.
And I always look at those guys.
It's like dude,
if you could take that sticktuitiveness right and actually apply it to something
you're good at,
right.
There'll be be great.
Yeah,
there'll be no stopping you.
That's,
that's fucked up.
It is.
But anyways,
let's go back cause I know people probably upset.
Okay.
I got off of the sort of social roles.
So just this cast was compiled.
So anyway,
so on a Saturday they were,
they needed to cast this part like I almost like a week or two weeks away from
shooting.
So on a Saturday,
which is unusual for show business and end in general to do anything on a
Saturday cause it's fucking Saturday,
you know,
show business.
They take all of December's off.
Yup.
The 4th of July is like a three week holiday.
You know,
like this business after September is Jewish holiday.
So that way in this business for them to do something on a Saturday,
there was a necessary,
you know,
like there was some urgency.
So I go in there and they're like,
you know,
we feel like you're,
you're this guy who you are and just read that.
And it was with me,
Tony Scott in the casting directors.
And I went through all the Dick Richie scenes and they will,
and I said to them,
cause I,
once that door opened and I was like,
I,
once I started thinking about tomorrow,
I was like,
this,
I love this part.
I love this character.
I remember I said to them,
don't let me leave,
um,
until I get it right.
You know,
and I,
and I went in and I kept reading and Tony,
you,
and you knew to say that a 24 it because it wasn't,
I wasn't in the hustle,
right.
It wasn't any hustle.
That's like,
like now you could say that that's like,
oh,
that's a smart thing to say.
Like,
I just,
cause I,
once I locked into the,
to the idea of me doing it,
I was like,
I had blinders on right when I was younger.
I would go in there with blinders on.
That's another,
that guy would be like,
Yo,
I'm going in here,
I'm getting this shit.
I'm doing this shit.
And that's it.
And,
and,
and but it was talking about that's psycho focus.
Yeah,
it was,
that's what I had because it was really,
it was a sense,
you know,
it was like I wanted it and it was,
it was right there.
So I went in there,
I did it,
I did a good job.
And I remember,
I remember one thing is that behind me,
like when I went to go set up in the room,
all the people that had been cast,
their head shops were,
were sitting behind me.
So it was like Christopher Walken,
Samuel Jackson,
Gary Oldman,
the all their headshots,
like blah to play in this part.
I remember seeing that and I was just like,
you know,
try not to pay attention to it.
But I remember,
I remember walking over to the thing and like seeing all of them and I was like,
I got to fucking do this,
I gotta get this shit right.
And,
um,
you know,
and,
and for,
and then they called me like two or three days later and they said,
you got the part.
And it was like the character in the movie,
cause it was like you got the part,
I got the part and I would just was so happy.
And,
and,
and then,
you know,
I remember I went to a,
a rehearsal was me and Christian Slater and Patricia Arquette and Patricia
Arquette was fine at that time.
She said she's fucking,
I had a huge crush.
Me Too.
And she was beautiful and she was sexy and really sweet and I was tripping out.
I was like,
she's fine.
And I just saw her in Indian runner and Christian Slater was like a part of my
youth watching him.
So,
and I'm just starting to be in the show business and I had done a few things and
he kind of your age too,
because he started so young.
He,
he might've been a little older,
a little older,
maybe not,
but I mean he was Christian Slater.
He was a huge star.
So I'm like tripping out and they're like,
you know,
yeah.
You know,
like we're like having this like bonding sessions and we're like,
I don't know,
we'd go out to eat and we're like eating lunch.
And I'm like,
what the fuck am I doing here?
You know?
And we're reading scenes and it's Tony Scott and he directed all these movies
and Tony Scott was just such a Tony Scott,
the way he treats actors and,
and the way he treated me at that time was a big thing because I was low man on
the totem pole.
At least I looked at myself like that and you know,
but I was also had ideas and thoughts about the character and he was so open
and,
and some things he would say,
great,
do that.
Somethings Z,
not,
don't do that.
But he gave me a voice and it was the first time where I felt like the first
time I had only done four or five things,
not like I've been trying to do it.
The treating you like you actually,
that you were a pro,
like you knew what you were doing,
your ideas were,
were worth listening to.
Exactly.
And some of them he liked and some of them he didn't.
And,
and,
but it really gave me confidence to go for like,
yeah,
I have a say in these things.
And he just was so positive and so much energy and,
and so enthusiastic every day and his energy would supersede everybody on the
crew.
And he just was,
was the uh,
like you know,
the guy that I actually was such a huge fan of,
it was devastated when he passed was Chris Pan,
Chris Penn,
what was it like?
Hangs and you got to,
because he was fun.
You,
you are in that,
that final shaft scene when you were covering up and everything.
He was great.
Crisp and you know,
what would the day this goes out,
if I'm going to,
I'm going to still send you a picture you could tweet with is a really guy,
I found these cool pictures from on the set.
Oh yeah,
I'll love it.
I'll send it to you.
They like,
you know,
like personal pictures that I,
that I took,
but Chris Penn,
Tom Sizemore and these guys were like,
Tom Sizemore was in everything at a time.
It,
Chris Penn with these words like,
dude,
you know,
and they were in a lot of shit and I'm like with them and they're like treating
me like I'm one of them in Chris pennants size where they're like regular dudes,
Chris Penn,
you know,
rest in peace also.
Yeah.
He's just a sweet guy.
And then there was a reservoir dogs like anniversary DVD that I watched with
this buddy of mine to Rosa.
And uh,
it had all of them like telling stories.
Yeah.
And Chris Penn stories were just like,
you could just see like,
he was just that,
that hanging out with a guy,
he's a sweet guy.
Yeah.
Just sweet.
So fun like that.
He,
I always felt like the way he,
he did,
I loved him.
A reservoir dogs and actually went on a closed range.
Oh yeah.
And I went on this whole like Chris Penn tear.
Yeah.
That anything he was in,
he did some obscure movie,
not obscure,
but it was one with Harvey Kaytel.
I can't remember what it was.
He was somehow his landlord is something,
I just remember him running up the side of the house trying to see if Keitel was
in there.
I can't remember what the name of the movie was,
but this is back when like blockbuster video.
Yeah,
I would,
I'd be going there like every day.
And then on this [inaudible] I just like reservoir dogs was like ground zero for
every actor in there.
I just went like off,
shoot,
just find all their stuff.
Just like watching all of that.
And I became a not like,
I stopped.
I was just such a huge fan of that guy was a,
well they like hilarious.
They were just hilarious and fun and,
and,
and warm and,
and big personalities.
And you know Victor Argo,
he's another guy passed away.
Victor Argo was one of the mobsters.
He was in taxi driver.
Yeah,
he,
he was,
he was the guy in the,
in the store.
When tack,
when,
when Travis shoots the guy,
when he tries to rob the Bodega,
you fucking the bees in a lot of square seems to means she saw him like
plugging,
I mean I'm bugging out that I'm working on the,
and then Samuel Jackson Need Sam's treat me like he knows me.
Right.
You know,
and,
and I'm sure you know,
and Val Kilmer is there and like I'd walk into the makeup trailer and val Kilmer
is doing is Elvis makeup and he's talking in the Elvis voice finding the
character and Gary Oldman.
I remember having a conversation.
He was,
it was crazy to sit next to val Kilmer who's doing Elvis.
It's crazy.
I'm tripping out.
I'm tripping.
I'm literally like chipping.
And then Brad Pitt cone.
What did you do?
How did you,
how did you
feed into that and go,
oh my God,
I'm not worthy to be here.
How did you keep yourself settled?
This is becoming like inside the box.
Yay.
What do you that?
Well,
what I would do and what I,
what I always do still to this day when I'm working with somebody,
like when I worked with you I had to get myself together.
Shut up.
No,
but you know what,
but you know it's the same thing.
Like my ego actually entertained that for half a second was on premium blend.
Maybe it was a thrill for him for at the time,
at the time I used to wear.
What I would do is I would,
I would enjoy and,
and,
and be a fan when it was time to be a fan,
I would never invade space or talk to them about any,
I never would go up to somebody and,
and,
and sort of do what I'm doing to you right now.
I wouldn't even do that.
I remember me and my friend Kevin Corrigan,
Hawaiian did playing the young gangster and we had worked together on my first
movie zebra head and we had worked together on something else in.
We were both like he got cast now.
We're friends now and I always look at Kevin like he's a real actor.
He's really good and he's been in tons of stuff.
He's on,
he's on Twitter.
We can tweet out Kevin and,
and,
and we saw Christopher Walken in,
in his wardrobe for the first time by the craft service.
And Kevin like Kevin would probably put Christopher Walken and he says number
one,
like I love Christopher Walken,
but I would go like,
Deniro is my number one.
Right.
And Kevin was a psych and I was like,
Yo,
you got to go talk to them.
Go to,
I'm hyping him up to go talk to a man like,
Yo,
you're like him.
Go talk to him.
And I remember he went over and talked to them and like the conversation,
you can tell it better.
It was kind of anticlimactic because you know,
Chris is bugged out.
Chris is so much more funnier than you would think cause,
but he,
at the time he was younger so he really had that spooky look and in the dark
black hair.
And he has the,
he had the wardrobe wants.
So he had the suit on with this long trench coat,
Vincent.
Oh,
wasn't Vincent Vega.
That's what was known as the blonde.
It was that core led or I don't remember,
he was the antichrist.
He was the antichrist reincarnated.
But I remember seeing it by craft service by that,
by the truck.
And I was like,
Oh shit.
And I mean it was just,
it was just such an exciting time.
And Gandel Feeney was in our boat,
gamble.
Feeney was not,
that was his first thing.
Right.
So he was even less than,
he had never acted in a movie before,
like he had done stage and so he was really nervous.
He was really freaking eyes.
So he was playing the mobster and I remember being there watching that scene
with him and Patricia Arquette and I'm just,
I would,
I would go to this,
this single hung out.
Oh yeah.
We'd go to the set just to,
just to go,
just to watch you be like the scene with Christopher Walken and Dennis Hopper.
I was there watching it.
Wow.
Yeah.
I was watching the Monitor.
It was a small city was a set and it was a small little guy as as that whole
thing was,
yeah.
Where you just sit there,
go on this.
This is crazy.
Crazy.
Yeah.
You knew that was the only,
that was the only movie that I've ever done where you,
I could say,
and I have a pretty good track record,
this zone who got ever done where I knew it was going to be great to all the
movies that I've done.
Highs,
lows,
good or bad.
Whenever I,
I,
we,
you knew it was special.
What it now when,
when they would go,
I got ask some Geek questions,
whatever.
All right,
so when they would say cut after he did a run through with a scene,
would there be any laughing and joking around or was it was,
it was,
it wasn't serious.
Like,
I'm taking myself seriously,
but I think the tone of the scene,
because it was serious,
you know,
and then I remember a couple of times a line would get messed up and you know,
there'd be a little bit of giggling and Tony,
you know,
I was behind the Monitor.
Right.
You know,
being super quiet and literally saying to myself,
I can't fucking believe I'm here.
Like tripping out.
Right.
Cause we all,
when you read that scene,
that was word for word,
you knew that scene.
You knew what it was going to be and just to hear them,
um,
I don't think I had headphones on listening to,
you could hear them,
you know,
just to hear them and be around it.
Like you knew you were watching something special.
Like I remember feeling like this is something special.
And then when you see the scene,
you know,
like I,
like I was there,
like,
I remember sitting there like watching it,
like this
is special,
you know,
and,
and um,
they,
each time they did it a little different or pretty hip,
they had their choices down.
They had their choices that walk and fluctuates a little bit.
Um,
but I think,
I think the scene was so well written,
this is like almost 20 years ago,
but the scene was so well written.
You didn't need to really,
once you meet your,
you're locked in,
you locked in because it was the writing Omani moments in that scene.
I love when walking clasps his hands together like a,
please don't make me whatever he says.
Yeah,
I spent a while since I've seen it,
but that,
that point where a hopper just like,
you know,
can I,
can I have one of those chesterfields and he's just like,
you know what,
I'm going out fucking swinging.
And when he finishes the story,
he sees that look on his face where he's like preparing himself,
I'm going to get killed.
And it was just a,
I don't know,
it's just one of the greatest scenes.
It really is.
It was.
It really is special.
It's special.
And,
and,
and you knew it was going to be special and when they got cast you knew it was
going to be great.
And how long did it take him to shoot it?
Like they probably had a whole afternoon all afternoon or maybe the whole day
like,
but they might have been had the whole afternoon because the thing about the
scene,
there's not much other than the acting,
there's not much logistically going on.
So he's not sitting there in that little trailer.
Yeah.
So like technically it might've been a whole day.
I know I was there for a few hours.
Where did they shoot that?
It was on a soundstage.
I don't want to say it wasn't Warner brothers.
It was a soundstage me,
I don't think it was Warner brothers.
I can't remember exactly where,
but it was this,
it was a stage,
I feel like it was Culver city ish,
but Sony,
you might've been Sony.
I think it was Sony.
Culver City.
So it was cool man.
It was exciting to watch that again immediately because I also like,
uh,
now that I've been out in la here for like five years,
I like,
she like the same way.
I like watching old movies about New York City.
Yeah.
And seeing stuff that's still standing there and they'll shift to change.
I'm starting to get like that for like la out here,
like just to to go to the locations sometimes.
Yeah,
I'll actually do that.
Like it bums me out that where they shot a reservoir dogs right out in Eagle
Rock didn't exist anymore.
And I met Jay.
I just want to at least is the alley still there right,
where they pull the cop out of the trunk.
Like I'm a geek.
I love that stuff.
Sports stadiums.
And I'm a geek for like this,
like this probably 20 like guy movies that I was like,
I don't give a fuck about,
you know,
you know what women want.
They shot that.
But you know,
like if there's a place where they shot Goodfellas,
if there's a place like that to pants,
reservoir dogs,
like the typical hacky guy list.
Yeah.
Of Film.
There's no left turns on the still the same way.
And my film and the films that I like,
but uh,
me neither.
But,
um,
let,
let's,
uh,
I want to talk to you did something about about hoop real quick,
unless you had something more to add.
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
I all I can say is it's,
it was a great experience.
It was everything that you would imagine everybody was,
was great.
And I mean,
Brad Pitt,
it just was,
it was special.
It was a special special film to be a part of and it was a special time for me,
you know,
it was just a good,
it was a suspect.
You were in one of those rare,
what before I described it,
you know,
two people continue on the right.
You were in one where there was like,
it seems like 10,
like everybody,
yeah.
Worked out of that.
In fact,
one of the guys who played in the scene,
uh,
the wok and scene with hopper,
the guy who was over at the fridge,
he speaks in a town called victor.
He's a good friend of mine.
Yeah.
He,
he was in,
um,
he's in tons of stuff.
He was in what the the wire.
He was in the wire.
Yeah.
He's in day works all the time.
And he's one of,
he was in there and he was in the scene,
but he's one of those guys.
He would have been back in the day when blockbuster video was still around.
He'd been one of those guys that you gradually like who is this guy,
this guy and then you just,
you figure out how to fuck dude.
How the fuck back in the day did you figuring out what other movies they did
before IMDP before I MDB.
You just had to like muscle it through that to be for good conversation piece.
Oh you'd buy like at that book you'd buy the book,
look at something that you wouldn't even be able to keep up the update.
Praise people.
You'd have to have a conversation.
Oh he was in this and you'd call friends and now you could just text.
And I am DB has having that conversation the other day,
like the,
the art of conversations and figuring things out as God.
Cause you could just be like hold on.
And you look at your phone and you got ever even thinking now on the,
on the,
on the new,
the new download and the iPhone where they have like the,
the uh,
that,
that gps thing,
right.
Which is great.
Now you don't have to look down at the phone.
You could just sit down and mindless,
silly,
right.
Make a right now make crazy hair that I don't mind,
but sometimes like,
you know,
like,
oh,
what was he in?
And you could kind of like,
oh yeah,
he was in that,
but you just get it all taken away from my MDB.
Now it's organic.
It gets rid of the debates and then Zach,
what he bucks says he was in the movie.
Then it will get resolved six weeks here.
But now you can't even get to the bet now.
So anyway,
you can a bedding I've got,
we got to talk sports.
Okay.
This is a fucking question here that I want to I about the nick.
I got,
I got to ask,
what about the thing you were saying to me about red or back?
You heard that what was happening?
You said that you said that you heard it and I was like,
I don't know.
That's your guy.
And you were like,
say that her,
you heard that he had a bungalow in West town and I was like,
that's a big skill or you should break down what I know where this is coming
from.
What this is coming from.
You being a Knicks fan and you have two little championship banners that have to
be turning yellow at this point.
They've been hanging up there so fucking long.
Yes,
that's true.
All right.
I wasn't going to drop in like that.
Okay,
but you did say something about red or black having a bungalow in west Hollywood
and there was a whole scandal.
I thought it was,
I understand it.
It's the jealousy.
Somebody brought that up to me.
I thought it was probably another sad ass fucking Knicks fan.
I was surprised.
I was like,
how could read horror of a bungalow in west Hollywood and that there was a whole
era you got into true romance hires here.
Emma favor.
You gave him a fucking handy and that's why we met on a Saturday when the
business was set though one of his cigars so to speak.
Um,
fucking New York.
Yes.
Basketball Fan,
Knicks fans,
all these fucking Knicks fans who've lived in Brooklyn and have been live,
die hard fucking Knicks fans.
All of a sudden the New Jersey Nets move into their burrow and then all of a
sudden they just all Brooklyn net fans.
And when are they all Brooklyn that fence.
Enough of them are that,
it's shocking to me the fact that when the day we're beating the Nixon,
the end when Brooklyn play,
when they played in Brooklyn and you knew that the uh,
the nets,
we're going to beat the next,
that all those people were standing up going brook.
Yeah.
Yeah,
Bro.
Like taunting the New York Knicks.
Like to me that's like some Benedict Arnold Shit.
Well,
I,
here's the thing,
here's the thing is,
is that he's explained me what the thing is,
I don't fucking get,
let me put it in Boston terms.
Let's say a team became the Dorchester ducks,
a basketball team,
and they were like the Dorchester,
like I don't know Boston so well,
but I know that right?
Dorchester's like,
uh,
like it's a,
there is a place in Dorchester and our ducks up there.
Okay.
But so you're on the right path toward let's say,
or let's see the Er to the door and let's say a team became like a sub team of
Boston and it was Dorchester and was like this neighborhood that's like very
close knit and it's a lot of pride and a lot of people have come through there
and it's,
it's a working class neighborhood.
Brooklyn is that,
I get that.
And I think it's cool that there's a team.
Go ahead.
I always that,
that's the thing.
So I think some people flipping are,
is because of that,
because it's like,
Yo,
this is Brooklyn.
Like if you're from Brooklyn,
you grew up a Knicks fan,
some Brooklyn Guide.
For me.
I'm curious who were going to be the Brooklyn net fence?
Well,
here's my question,
but the Knicks or on a fucking tear.
Yeah,
they beat the heat last night.
They're like,
what?
Like 12 and four,
something like that.
13 and four something crazy.
Right?
I don't count my chickens with that shit.
Okay.
By the way,
you could get into that,
say hypothetical.
They finally pushed through this year and they win a championship and all those
people in Brooklyn who've been sitting there going to be pissed and they went
through all,
you know the finger roll instead of the dunk.
They went to all the fucking shit with the Knicks.
Right.
And all this.
And like you're not going to be real years and years and yes.
And let's just like,
I look,
I guess I get it to a certain extent.
If you're a kid,
like I get like little kids if like,
Oh Brooklyn,
I'm from Brooklyn,
I'll be on that.
But if you're some guy in his 30 years old,
so what have you started watching when you're six 20,
you got a quarter of a century of fucking just rooting for this team and then
all of a sudden that fucking New Jersey Nets and New Jersey Nets,
the New Jersey Nets.
I the fucking,
it's,
it's an interesting thing.
I don't know why it is,
is it going to be a conflict of interest?
Because the crazy thing is they're both doing well and if they play each other
in the playoffs,
it's gonna.
It's gonna be interesting.
Like I would be curious like when the,
at the Brooklyn Arena,
at the Barclays Arena,
which I haven't been to,
which I'm going to go to,
that annoys me.
How nice that places compared to with the south,
except I just saw it on TV.
It's fucking ridiculous.
I heard it's really nice.
They got the,
uh,
the little suites that they have up there,
this fear like little mini brownstones.
That's,
that's what the,
that's what the floor is supposed to look like.
Like,
I guess if you have a nice Brownstone,
that's the pattern of the wood on the floor.
That's crazy.
And then you look at the fucking Celtics.
Yeah,
we have the parquet floor,
whatever,
but they just,
it's just a of cinder blocks.
No carer.
You knock that shit box down the Boston Garden.
Dude.
Get the fuck out of my house right now.
Shit.
Box down.
Fuck you talking about this whole down right.
Then wait,
wait,
wait.
I know this is coming from.
Can I use for you guys?
I'm standing up now.
Where you fucking guy.
This guy's about to assault me.
No,
no.
Where you guys could never win.
I get it.
Kenny Skywalker.
Listen,
Bernard King,
listen,
Patrick Ewing,
you guys came through and they all lost to the,
I just want to say,
I just need to say Yam rock.
You guys knocked that shit.
Hold down.
And then you have a new arena.
What's it called?
Fleet Center.
The fucking fleet center.
You should or you shouldn't call it.
You should've done that.
He should have,
you know,
made it tie tech did and stuff.
But you cut corners.
What does that mean?
Make a nice like the Barclays make it nice like you know,
do something nice to it but you want it to make a shitbox knocked the one down
and then make another shitbox that fleets and I walked by it.
It looks like she should go to the Boston Garden.
I've never been there.
You sound like a guy who's never gone to the Boston Garden.
I never been in it.
What do you consider?
Did you think?
Yeah.
No cause it wasn't mind you go me.
You go on that tour of Fenway.
We really get to know we did get on with your insult.
That fucking place.
That new is that not put all the history.
The history is great.
I can go home museum for his laptop.
It was a piss hole.
If they sold mouse ears,
they're like,
you were at Disneyland,
you would have bought him.
You loved it.
Bill told me you love me now he's just serene.
A cunt to side from the history.
Is it not a shitbox you I could even fit in some of those seats.
It's a shit hole blocking here.
It's a shit hole.
It's,
it's,
it's character.
Okay,
so Barclays wanted to revamp their and make a nice arena.
God bless him.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not giving them shit.
I think it's great that they did that,
but what I'm saying is that you went from,
Oh,
the fans that you went from the Boston Garden.
Yeah.
Being a shit hole.
A step.
Was it?
I mean,
if you consider winning 16 titles,
they're a shit hole.
I didn't say what they weren't good.
I'm just saying the garden itself was a piss box.
Listen,
I'm not gonna say it didn't need a coat of paint.
I'm not going to say that the electrical didn't crap out on you every once in a
while.
I'm not saying that.
I'm not saying that all right,
but spending in the fucking Madison Square Garden,
my friend,
they don't call the lead.
What do they call it?
What do they call Madison Square Garden going?
Or they call it,
what do they call Madison's Gurgle the most,
the most famous arena in the world.
It'll never get knocked out.
This is the thing,
and we revamped it.
First of all,
that's the second one.
They already knocked down the first one.
I know that New Year history,
I note that the first one was a piss box.
Secondly,
the fucking most famous arena in the world.
You know who came up with that?
The people who fucking own the thing.
Well,
they're,
they're good marketing people,
right?
That's what I'm saying.
When I fight,
I fight.
What if I,
I anoint myself a fucking nickname.
You got to start.
You should call them,
discover them for something,
some kind of,
something about the fleet center because that's a Michael Jackson just said,
you know,
like almost not even in Boston.
It's like I went there.
I was like,
where is this place?
It's like,
no,
it's in downtown Boston.
Downtown.
I don't know.
It just seemed weird.
Don't like,
no,
I like basic.
We've won a bunch of titles.
I liked it.
I was us working on the heat boards.
You like,
they're the swan boats.
I liked it.
I liked the food.
I respect the sports.
I could.
You not respect them.
I love Larry Joe Berger.
It's his birthday today.
Larry Joe Bird.
Love Him.
Is it really real big Boston fan?
It's Larry.
Joe Burns.
He'll rest his soul.
It's,
we're taping this on the seventh.
It's his birthday too.
I never knew they had the same bird then.
He loved Larry Bird.
I asked him why didn't you like him over Magic Johnson cause he goes,
cause Larry made me feel like I could make the league too.
Right?
Yeah,
he made it feel like anyone could do it.
Yeah.
So let's see.
This is,
this is the old thing about the Boston Celtics and I told him you something
after your thing.
Go ahead.
I grew up hating the Celtics.
I couldn't even appreciate how good they were and how good Larry Bird was.
Although I x because we killed the next everybody.
I hated them and people used to have,
my nickname in Brooklyn is Larry Bird because of the way I look and you know
dude,
if you could grow one of those awful mustaches,
remember coloring.
I don't look like Larry Bird.
No,
I don't look like,
and we just said,
I just cause I play basketball and I have,
you know,
but I never had a fucking what do they have a Shag or what does the thing had
the haircut every white dude had in the 80s everybody had that idea.
I do have that.
They never Molly,
but I was feathered.
You feathered it.
I did feather what she did.
I should have a patient bet you had some sort of a,
with your liking of hip hop and everything.
You probably had one of those thin Puerto Rican I wish shaped up and I sit down
at the time when Larry looked like Larry Bird.
No,
at the time I was too young to have one but are also with,
but,
but I'll tell you something.
I told you this,
I really love the Celtics team that they have now and what they did to Miami
last year,
pushing them to game seven and that was one of my favorite team.
Celtic teams evolve all heart.
I was rooting for them so hard and,
and I've had mixed feelings about Kevin Garnett pushing that.
He's a Celtic.
I respect him.
I love his career.
He's awesome.
The way he plays his inspires me and what I do,
he plays at the same level to,
and they went out on their fucking shields last year.
I almost beat those mother fuckers cause I don't care who it is.
The Knicks,
the nets,
the Utah Jazz,
the fucking New Orleans Pelicans or whatever they're becoming.
Somebody needs to beat the heat.
You don't like to he see me.
I feel that way about the Lakers.
I hate the Lakers and I actually think Koby Bryant,
this will get me some fucking emails.
I think he's one of the most overrated crazy five time champions.
Crazy time.
Well go ahead.
I can argue it.
What it,
what can you say he,
he's been on nothing but pile on teams.
Like everything that they give Lebron Shit for doing going into Miami.
Coby has been living,
he just hasn't had to leave cause they bring everybody and do what he did the
other night when he walked off the court with 10 seconds left.
Did you see that shit?
Yeah.
Dude.
You know what?
It was four seconds,
four seconds,
whatever you did,
you left your teammates sitting out there.
All that does is breed resentment.
That guy is a cancer.
He's one of the greatest individual one on one players ever since Jordan,
I would say he's number two behind Jordan,
but he doesn't make anybody better around him.
He may eat pig breeds fucking resentment.
I agree.
I so love cozy kills me is that he's a blood.
He's a,
he's an animal and that's what he has over the rest.
Listen,
here's a story.
Here's a debate.
I have to say this before.
People see you see Colby,
who to play with the five stitches.
Do you think Coby Bryan would have played with the five stitches?
And I'm not disrespected,
Carmelo,
I love you,
but do you think Colby Bryan would be missing a leg and he would play.
He would have played against Miami last night.
That's the difference between him and everybody else,
but this is my criticism of the guy.
The guy does not know how to get along with the other fucking people.
I,
he's a savant.
He,
he,
he's the Bobby Fischer of basketball.
Fucking ran shack out of town.
Like he said the other day they'd go,
you're going to score your 30th thousand point.
Did you ever think you do that?
And he says,
well,
you know,
I'm not into individual stuff.
I've just was.
To me it was always about champions.
It's like that's why you ran shack out of town at the height of his fucking
powers.
You'd won three championships in four years.
Shaq leaves the very next year he wins one with the heat.
But you can get,
but you got your 50 a game.
I'm not saying that he,
he hasn't done some things that he probably regrets.
He would never say this,
but I'm saying I love that guy in his game and I've learned to appreciate him
and,
and his tenacity and his intensity.
Let's listen.
They're not saying anything that nobody hasn't said.
All they do is blow Coby and boredom.
He makes your fucking giving him,
I'm a Knicks fan.
So what?
I'll give him what?
He deserves a fucking hand job.
And you know what?
I was at that break.
First of all,
let's go back.
No,
he would have played with the stitches that Carmelo Mike Dunn,
you're talking too loud.
Carmelo.
I love.
Carmelo was retarded.
He's sick and he's becoming a great,
great team player and a winner and and and,
and all that.
She is and I,
I've definitely seen that and his talent is immense.
His,
his talent does,
he meant,
but last night while I was watching that gave me like he might play,
you might not play,
you know what I played with last night with five stitches on your non shooting
it Allen Iverson where the played Koby Bryant Woods.
Michael Jordan.
I'm not questioning the guy's heart.
Know anyone else in the NBA.
His inability to get along with other fucking guys has fucked the Lakers.
Like I feel like dude,
the amount of times,
I'm trying to think like all those championship runs in the finals.
When is he just taken over a fucking series?
Has He ever done that?
Didn't he do that against you guys when that series that we just not we,
they just beat you like what was it?
This was his quote.
The loan.
They just beat us last time.
He said,
I don't know how we won that game.
The MVP of the game,
seven of that series was,
it was the fucking officiating crew.
We,
we,
I'm not repeat June called like fucking beat you.
Yes they did.
They won.
And this is my thing,
dude.
If somebody beats me like the fucking giants,
they fucking beat us.
I don't,
I don't mean in the Superbowl last year and the Superbowl before that.
You mean when they beat the Patriots twice and seeing them last?
You remember they did.
Oh,
that's right.
sorry.
Okay.
When do you mean when they beat them?
When you guys were 18 and older.
I just gonna let you get through this.
Go ahead.
And then they beat you in the Superbowl.
Are you talking about that year or you saw my last year?
I'm talking about last year when they beat you in this role was,
was that last year?
I'm sorry,
I get confused with talking about you feel better.
I'm just,
I get confused though.
Better bitch about when the giants beat the New England patriots in the last two
Superbowl because it happened twice.
Twice.
I give it up,
I definitely give it up.
Okay.
But my thing about the a,
a Celtics,
this is,
I'm just saying as a fan here,
Celtics,
Lakers,
finals should be decided by the players.
You put your fucking whistle away,
you don't call 35 fucking files in one team sites here and there.
And I sat there and watched the Lakers make a fourth quarter comeback against
the Celtics from the fucking fall line.
I remember,
if you tell me one memorable fucking shot in that fucking game,
there's only one was metal world peace.
He hit a three pointer and the only thing that made it memorable is was he was
so fucking high on whatever the fuck his therapists gave him.
He was waving to the crowd like he was already at the fucking parade.
That was,
that was the only memorable.
Other than that,
it was received Wallace just standing there as Coby jumps into them,
which I can see a no call but to call a fucking offensive foul like,
and Colby said at the end again,
because I don't know how we won that game.
All right,
so I'm saying that this guy,
he's sick and individual.
The individual.
Yeah.
You're one of those guys probably thought Peyton manning was better than Brady
too,
for the longest.
Fuck no,
no,
no.
I'm not saying there's not flaws that I
pay.
My copay might be hating my hating Coby phase two,
but I don't listen.
I respect you think you'd think the sick.
You would think that.
I hate the guy.
I don't,
I don't.
But my fucking thing about that guy is he's really in a very openly way a
fucking cancer.
He's the Bobby Fischer of the NBA.
He's like,
he,
he's,
you know what he is?
He's reversed magic Johnson.
Magic Johnson could walk into a locker room and look at me on his team
inexplicably and he could somehow figure out where he needed to give me the
ball,
which would probably be right under the fucking net.
And he would,
I would somehow get eight points.
I agree.
Colby would walk in and would fucking be like,
get that fucking piece of Shit Outta here.
And he'd tell you to get the fuck out.
And people think that's because he gives a fuck.
He gives a fuck about himself through those championships.
He doesn't go to the front fucking office because he wants the Lakers and the
team to win a championship.
He like that winning championships is another individual stack for him.
It's all about fucking him.
That's that.
That's my complaint about that.
I'm not going to argue or debate with you about any of that shit.
I think the guy's retarded though.
I say that in three minutes away in an in an effective one on one,
one sheer he days.
The fact that he,
he's never,
you're never gonna see him dip.
He's never going to dip.
No Louie.
Absolutely.
But the thing about it is though is if you really give a fuck about winning
championships,
you don't walk out on your teeth.
Dude.
He made everybody on that team.
His bitch at that point,
I know becomes his dude in fucking Dwight.
When did it become Dwight Howard,
by the way?
What?
Are there any saying?
Everybody goes to Dwight Howard and la though the stew and those guys on the
[inaudible] sale last night on on TBS when I was watching your next beat,
the heat.
Everyone's going,
Dwight Howard.
I don't know.
I don't like his headband.
I think it's fucking with them.
Take that had been,
how old were you?
What are you doing?
Put It on straight.
Do something.
And I'm like the headband though.
They've brought every,
but another thing too about his five.
They brought everybody in short of Jesus Christ to help this guy get five
fucking rings.
And then they compare him to Colby Bryant who had Luc Longley and bill car to
Jordan.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
As you to Jordan.
That's how he won with,
give me a fucking break.
All right.
Listen.
The rings of the Rings and,
and that's,
that ring is the thing.
That's not it.
It's different.
It's like the steroid era and not the steroid ever.
This is the pile on error.
They should,
there should be,
oh,
it is the pilot error.
Give me a fucking,
Miami started it.
Miami started that bullshit.
The Lakers been piloting
that was a pylon champion.
Yeah,
so I can fucking admit that.
Yeah.
Pile on championship.
Miami's was a pile of champion to Shaq,
Phil Jackson and all those fucking guys that,
that was a pilot like do they like the Yankees?
A fucking bass.
I agree.
They just,
every year they're going to be signing these giant green can guys.
I agree.
I'm an elite this fan like that.
I'm not going to sit here and defend the Lakers,
eh,
the way like that.
I'm just saying I want somebody to make sure they beat the heat.
I love the showtime Lakers and as much as I hated those guys,
like back then when like they had a crew tool,
but this is,
the thing happened.
It was like draft picks,
but the whole Mba was different then.
I know,
but I wish it went back to that where it was just like year after fucking you've
got to groom your guy.
When the six came in,
you knew who was coming to town and you had fucking three years of fucking hate.
I agree.
Now it's like the guy you fucking hate the most the next year,
all of a sudden he's on your team.
I agree with in the fucking hat on and it's no Ray Allen did I?
I'm with Kevin Garnett.
I don't say hello.
I'm on that shit.
I is a Boston fan.
Don't mind what he did cause he wasn't ours to begin with.
We got him as a free agent.
Fine.
But he knew what he was.
Go there.
Don't go down there to Miami because that's the way it's done now they all
fucking hang out and drink pina coladas and the off season.
They were all friends.
What have you,
you and you and me all got on the stage.
Bullshit.
And then we'll,
and then we're like Larry and magic seat.
You're coming around to my side.
I would say,
I don't want you to know that,
hey,
it's all that Aau shit.
They all grew up together.
That's the problem with the MBA.
They all grew up together playing basketball since were 1112 years old.
You're not going to fight them.
Moses Malone met bill in beer on a basketball court.
Moses Malone met doctor met me when against Kareem Abdul Jabbar when they came
out their magic and Larry,
the first time they went out,
they met face to face,
was playing against each other.
Right.
Does shit they do now they,
they travel and they're 11,
12.
Everybody's kissing and hugging and they're all friends.
That's what's wrong with the NBA.
You think the fucking Lani Shelton was hanging out with Darryl Dawkins?
Hell fucking no.
You know Lonnie Shelton is you ani sung is a Seattle.
The Seattle supersize me.
He was like a goon.
You looked at Bob Linear and artists Gilmore were like,
you know,
yucking it up during the off season and in,
in,
in Cabo.
Fuck no,
these guys were all kissing and hugging.
That's what I,
so my thing is,
even in the NFL and seed is doing,
cause I already always sound like a fucking crabby old man with a Tampon.
But like my thing is,
if that's how it's done now,
that's how it's done now.
But don't fucking put these people in the same,
uh,
category is Larry Byrd who,
you know,
come and we played like a bunch of sissies last night.
No fucking lay up this game and like that type of Shit won't have is gone.
It's gone.
You'll never see the choose like when doc and Larry fought,
that was shocking.
You will never see that happen.
Now you like Lebron and Kolby won't get into a fist fight with Dwayne wade did
to Coby last year during the All star game.
See,
that's why I like Coby Bryan.
See like memory,
like I liked them too.
I like him,
but I'm just saying like he's on that shit.
But this is the thing on that alliance claims shit.
Colbys if he acts like a fucking asshole,
like Steven A.
Smith was still blowing the guy.
It's just like,
dude,
he walked off this from his fucking team.
Call them hour.
I agree.
But Colbys on that shit though.
That old school shit.
Like,
he's like,
fuck these guys.
He's literally like,
fuck these guys and I liked that.
Fuck these guys.
And he's like,
fuck these guys.
I think he's like,
fuck these guys when he's playing you and at the end of the year he goes,
fuck this.
Those guys just beat us.
Get,
get us their best guy.
I don't know about all that me,
but I like that.
He's like,
fuck these guys and I liked that.
Garnette is like,
fuck these guys and you want to go to the Miami Heat then fuck you Jesus.
Shuttlesworth fuck you.
I liked that.
He's like,
I see what you're saying.
No,
Colby is a hard guy to have even as a fucking Celtic fan,
but my,
my,
it just pisses me off when they compare these guys today where he's the closest
comparison you can make though.
Now we isn't.
Yes,
he is.
And all the guys left.
Coby.
Brian is an old city.
Paris is not even close.
I didn't see,
I say,
I said he's the closest and you're saying not even close.
He doesn't make anybody around a better,
he's all about himself.
He's not about the team.
I agree.
Like magic wasn't like that.
Larry wasn't like that doctor Jay was one of those guys weren't like that.
That tenacity day.
Berlin was like that.
Yeah.
Well that's a whole other story.
I'm just saying.
I'm just saying,
I'm just trying to,
Russell is the most overrated icon.
It's an esports.
They was like,
it was like when Lebron was playing in high school,
you know those clips of him playing ice,
cause it's all your pain.
The pimple faced,
you know,
the 17 year olds.
That's what Bill Russel was when he's playing in the NBA.
I'm not saying he wasn't great,
but he never got to compete against,
you know,
consistently good competition.
If you're only at William Chamberlain,
he's not a good just,
just ruled Baylor,
Jerry West nine centers.
These are not centers.
Of course,
you're going to block every shot.
You're seven feet every with the biggest guys I know would be white guys a lot.
We beat you guys.
A lot of this is coming from just saying that whole,
the 11 championships,
whatever.
Look,
now I'll,
I'll go,
I'll go with this.
Um,
what would bill,
what would bill Russell be now?
He'd be like,
he'd be like,
uh,
you know what?
He'd be in the NBA Today.
He'd be like surge a Baka if he was lucky.
No,
that's,
he was lucky.
No,
that's if you teleported him.
But if he actually came up in this era with his,
with his talent,
with Bass,
the basketball knowledge,
I'm gonna get so much trouble for saying that the nutrition that they have,
they'd all be bulked up.
You can't compare different hours.
But I will say this early on,
you know,
like those,
every sport has that fucking team that,
that went on a run back during the 23 skidoo years.
You know what I mean?
And it's just like you could do,
yeah,
you can,
you just like,
all right,
well,
I mean,
I probably could have made the fucking league back then meet soon as it just
came in.
I mean,
which I couldn't,
but the only period,
like the person,
like,
like the Yankees are a team as much as I fucking hate him.
Where the,
what makes them the greatest franchise ever.
I think more so than,
you know,
the 27 that they talked about is that they went babe Ruth to Lou Gehrig to Joe
Dimaggio to Mickey Mantle.
You talking like 40 fucking years of getting Jordan?
Yes.
In a row and everybody else's scouting people.
When we fucking sold Babe Ruth,
we were morons.
That's why I hated the curse of Babe.
I felt that was a cop out.
It's like,
no,
we're fucking idiots.
You know,
there was an occurrence.
It was just,
you guys fucked up unbelievably and deserved every,
not the fans,
but the organization does or they could've got done any jack,
you guys,
those titles,
they could've given a don't give us what title,
the two titles you want.
I don't even,
they don't really count and I'm on the time of good.
This makes me feel,
I didn't like any Laker fan lists me bitching about Colby.
How happy that made them.
Those titles don't even count to me.
Yeah,
why would they?
They just don't count.
Yeah.
Why would they come to you?
Because they're just whatever meg it God got,
Hey,
we were just down three games to none to a $215 million team.
You know,
we came back.
Oh you do?
Do you know that'll never happen again unless the New York Yankees steward to
have another $215 million team with like four first ballot hall of famers choke
away four games in a row.
You're never going to see it again unless the fucking Yankees do it.
Cause they're the only ones who can afford a $250 million fucking team.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's all I'm gonna say.
Yes.
Yeah.
You just gotta.
You gotta take that one the same way.
I got to take your giant shit.
Oh,
you mean when they beat the fucking patriots?
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
That's crazy.
It all circles back.
It's a circle of life.
Speaking the curse of the bay.
Somebody wanted me to ask you this.
Go ahead.
Let me see here.
Evidently you were on one of those ghost stories.
Yes.
Celebrity ghost stories thing and they bluntly asked her,
where the fuck is this?
Ha ha ha ha.
It was totally real.
That's what they said.
So you knew they were going to say,
they wouldn't say how full of Shit I got to see this here.
No,
but we got parked to the part two is even better.
It's coming up on 'em fuck,
I don't know the name of the new show,
but it's uh,
something,
something.
And we went back to school.
Me and the friend that it's pretty good.
Well tell me what happened cause I missed and I know I'm a familiar with the
show where it's like celebrities had a gun counter with a ghost man and,
and I,
and I went in there,
he told it and it was real and that you believe in ghosts.
I said eye for eye.
I had a ghost encounter.
I can't find the fucking thing.
All right,
fine.
Second,
wait a second.
So take me through this cause I think,
I think he'd just afraid of the dark.
No,
no,
I'm not.
It was in,
it was in high school.
I went to a really old high school.
Billy Cunningham went to Doug Moe and Barbara Streisand and the rapper special
Ed.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's a pretty eclectic,
it was eclectic mix of p Rasmus whole high school in Brooklyn.
Okay.
And we were,
wait,
I thought you from Manhattan.
I went to high school.
I had gotten kicked out of every two.
We read an hour and seven towel effort of listens this shit or fucking,
I got to hear the get go.
Let's,
we'll wrap it up with what?
The ghost story.
It's not worth it and trust me.
Yes it is.
I promise.
I want to give you shit about this.
I promise you it's not.
There's other things.
Give me enough.
Fuck you.
You saw a ghost.
I want to hear this.
All right.
So we were in high school,
we got locked in a room and she was,
we does 15 years old and we've got the shit scared out of us.
So you know,
my friend,
boom,
we went on the thing and I talked about it,
but the,
the part,
no,
no.
Slow it down.
Where did your in you,
you were in this high school.
It's really old.
It's a really old high school.
There's ghosts in there.
Like it's known.
It's known that this goes,
so you're in there and you're going to your science class.
Is this after hours?
It was after school.
It was like during um,
dusk goes number come out during the day.
We had a,
we had the tension,
you had detention.
It was like,
it was like the urban urban aversion of the breakfast club.
It was like the Brooklyn version of the breakfast club.
So you know,
it was like that.
And we got instead of weed and he had coke,
coke,
crack sniffing it.
Not Drinking Beers in forties.
But even if you know,
you know,
they make things seem heightened on the,
on the celebrity ghost stories.
So it's you again,
I don't want to talk about it.
I went,
oh my God.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
Okay.
Well we just,
deep boats is,
it's too hard to talk about.
It's emotional.
It makes me,
I don't want to get so because we're taught here today and it brings you to a
bad spot.
I want you to have a good time.
I don't want to bring up your true life ghost story that you told.
Yeah.
The reason I wanted to tell you the reason why I'm wearing my,
it's changed the subject.
So we usually to wearing my giants tee shirt and my matching giant sneakers is
because my son has his playoff game today.
Looks like a make a wish kid with that matching shit on it.
But go ahead.
Cause we're,
we're,
we have a playoff game today.
I have to get to the field and hour and a half before to check the grass,
make sure everything's good.
Cause you know,
it's,
it's the,
uh,
it's uh,
what's he playing?
Soccer,
football,
football.
But you know,
he's 10.
I,
you know,
I'm the inspiration,
I'm not the coach,
but I'm the,
the inspirational leader of the team and I have to get the firemen Ed.
Exactly.
Exactly what I am.
Nice.
Exactly what I am,
um,
uh,
of the,
of the Barrington of the Barrington,
uh,
a 10 year old,
league.
I am the firemen at the time.
We won the Superbowl last year and we have our playoff game today.
And you know there's other yelling at the other little kids.
That's right,
bitch.
I know.
I never,
I,
I'm,
I'm actually very good in that way.
But I will say one game that we played,
it wasn't Tony Gonzalez,
his kid,
but Tony's gung exalts.
His kid was on that team this year we were losing and I was,
I was like,
we're going to win this game with three touches and every time we'd score a
touch on,
not Tony's a Gonzales's kid,
but he was on their team.
But this fat kid,
again,
not,
not Tony's kid,
was a,
what's the big deal?
You,
you just got one touchdown and I ignored him the first time.
It as a kid in the crowd?
No,
on their team because I'm going nuts.
So this is a fat kid on the other team on the other nine year old at this point,
10 between 10 and 12 he could be 10 or 12 the way you make him sound 12 so you
don't sound that bad.
That's the looking at whole fat 12 year olds hockey.
He's hockey me to,
what's the big deal is,
hey,
I don't say anything to them.
And then we score again.
Now we're down six points.
These guys,
he said this to me,
this is a little kits at,
this guy's getting so excited every time they score,
I'm looking over and I'm like,
and then I said,
hey,
don't,
don't speak to me.
You're not allowed to talk to me.
And then when we won the game,
we find that when the head and yeah,
because we're only going to want to be like you fat.
Fuck listen,
Twinkies.
Okay.
And then you know,
stock up.
And you could say that back in the day too,
right?
You can't,
you could,
you could literally Duke it out with his dad and in the end,
even though his blood and teeth in the ground,
that would be no loss,
nothing,
nothing.
Anyway,
we won the game and after the game,
you know,
you'd line up in the handshake and Toby,
you saw me cause he was like,
this guy's nuts.
But I'm always really,
you know,
I know what you're in the stance,
so why are you out on the field?
I'm inspirational leader on vocational coach.
So I was actually,
because we were losing,
they brought me at halftime to come over there and give a speech.
Oh,
there you go.
So I gave a speech,
it's like my version of Hoosier is every week.
I love it.
But anyway,
so I gave,
I gave fats on a nice,
a good,
a good five and I'll pop on the,
on the ass after the game and said good game.
And they get mad enough.
No,
but he knew that we had a little thing and it was like,
you know,
it was like that moment in,
um,
in the hangover,
you know,
when the little kid was like,
but I was the little kid.
I was like,
fuck you.
So hopefully we'll play them in the,
in the playoffs there that the chiefs there,
the chair,
where are they at right now?
What level is it?
The,
is it the first round of the playoffs as a city is the first round of the
playoffs and we're playing the kid,
we're playing,
I have a speech plan out today and it's about us being a team and being brothers
and them having just one good player.
And Are you going to let one good player,
Pete,
you brothers,
something like that.
Hey,
I don't want to blow my load right now,
but it's a really good speech.
I haven't written down third.
You know what,
we're at the end here.
And you know what I completely forgot to bring up that I,
that I love was the documentary.
Oh thank you.
On a,
on a tribe called quest.
Thank you.
And there was a question that if people didn't see it,
like I'm,
I'm one of those people came way,
way late to the game.
You talked about that when it comes to all a rap,
hip hop or yell,
you're supposed to call it.
And uh,
so like there's a bunch of stuff that,
you know,
like I was obviously familiar with them and I knew a lot of their stuff.
Know,
Yo,
MTV raps would put down,
but I didn't know to the level all of this stuff.
It was such a like,
even if you're not a fan of that music,
you'll love it.
You'll love this documentary.
Then you'll actually like me,
you'll start downloading all their music is for everybody.
I call him the rolling stones,
a hip hop there.
Music is,
you can't not like the music or the Beatles of hip hop like their music is that
accessible in all ages.
Tribe called quest.
It was a pleasure doing it.
The name of the film is beats,
rhymes and life.
The travels of a tribe called quest.
It was a,
then everything's good.
Everything's smoothed over.
I know there was a little bit of drama.
They moved.
I mean I think you know that was all,
because they are very protective and and and,
and you know,
they understand what the legacy of a tribe called quest means to the fans.
I do too.
That's why I made the movie.
I came at it as a fan.
I loved the group.
I didn't know anything about them and I didn't think it showed them in a bad
way.
It just made me want to download this stuff in Britain and respected them.
That's why I made the movie.
That's why I made it wasn't the first time saw a documentary director got into
with the subject of a documentary and it's not going to be the last time.
Um,
I think it takes,
I think feet people freak out right before it comes out.
You're like,
oh my God,
is this God?
Is this going to ruin me?
It'd be,
I understand you do you know a Burt Reynolds I heard before a boogie nights
came,
right?
Like freaked out.
He walked out of a screening.
Yeah,
maybe even fired his agent.
He was just like,
what?
Why didn't you put me in this piece of shit?
Now it's like everybody loves it.
Trust me.
If somebody was filming a documentary of,
of,
of my life and they were doing this segment,
you think I'd want this segment and our celebrity goes through thing to be,
I'd be like,
no,
that can't make it into the fucking movie.
So I understand.
I understood because I was,
I've thought about a lot.
I'd be like,
how would you feel someone who's making a doc that was beyond just me being the
incredible,
you know,
highly achieved actor,
it became this personal thing if they just didn't want to go into that.
Me As a highly,
highly,
highly achieved actor.
Now I'm just playing.
But I,
you know,
when it gets personal and you like,
you started to see like the intimacy and you see yourself in moments that you
forgot about because they're being filmed throwing screen.
It's a vulnerable position.
So that's all it was.
And I made the movie out of love and,
and I think at the end of the day they know that and,
and the movie's gone on to,
you know,
it's really like,
what else do you get?
Do you got anything you want to hype before we,
uh,
Nah man.
I mean,
the only thing I want to hype is,
is the New York Knicks.
I want to hype the giants,
you know,
starting to do their little midseason fumble and you know,
we got a movie coming out in,
in,
in I think it's April 5th to heal it comes Sandra,
Sandra Bullock and bill burrs.
Incredible.
And he's funny.
He's good.
He's got red hair and a red beard now.
Yo,
he,
there's,
there's going to be bill burrs going to be doing this thing in this movie.
It's going to be,
it's a funny movie and uh,
all right.
Do,
I'm really psyched that you came on this.
I'm glad to do it.
Definitely.
We were going to,
we might have to have you on again to talk shit when the Patriots finally beat
your ass in the fucking super bowl.
We should do us and we got to go.
We'll do it.
He will do a thing for the heater.
There'll be after football season,
it'll be going into the playoffs of,
of,
for basketball and baseball.
Just be starting.
We'll do it.
I'm always a pessimist.
I hate our defense.
I hate our secondary for the Patriots.
I think the best thing we have going for our secondary as their running game
because it keeps them off the God damn field.
You know your shit.
I'm going to tell you this right now,
like I think,
I think,
I think we're going to lose to the Broncos in the playoffs.
I really do.
Because would that be the first round that would wildcard,
right?
No,
no,
no.
We were,
uh,
no,
Brock wasn't gonna win the division like,
and we're going to win out.
So maybe like second round,
I just feel like,
I think,
you know,
because Bella check knows how to get into Payton's head.
But like,
I just,
I just don't believe in our defense.
And also was that when we played the Broncos,
earliest year of Peyton had only been with them for 60 days.
Yeah.
That doesn't count.
Now he's going to be emails.
Yeah.
Now he's jelling with them and he's gonna have another hundred and 20 days.
It'd be like [inaudible] to 300 fucking days in 240 days in or something.
He's something else.
Yeah.
No,
no,
absolutely.
And I'm so glad that he came back because who would want in him to end?
I didn't want,
you know what?
I ended up realizing that I never really hated paint man,
and what I really fucking hated was the disrespect that they weren't given Brady
his fucking do.
It's a long fucking argument and at the end of it,
you know there's no way as a football fan you can't love that guy,
but I,
I think that that defense is good enough with Brady Bella check.
He can never count that.
That's going to be a brutal game.
What about Greg Koski?
Is he going to come back?
I love Greg Koski by the way.
Yeah,
I don't know.
It's what he break his fall.
I guarantee you he'll be,
he'll be there.
He's,
I love him.
I love God.
Koski he's,
he's,
he's good.
He reminds me of [inaudible] Welker if he caught that fucking ball,
you're not talking about that little loop that barely read.
Come on man.
You lost the game show.
We fucking cut your throats and blood spilled twice.
First Time it happened,
you came back,
you got surgery,
rehabilitation,
and then we slid them again.
He left us on lights and fog.
You can't got to play it up again.
We got to play you guys again.
All right,
Michael.
Thank you so much,
God dwelling.
Aw,
man.
You're fucking awesome.
I appreciate it.
And that story was fucking,
that was really good.
It was incredible.